j'ouvre maintenant notre second débat
vous le savez dans cette émission
cherche le plus souvent à prendre du
recul à se décaler de l'actualité du
jour alors ce soir je vous propose de
revenir sur cette étude de la Fondation
Jean Jaurès publié il y a deux mois
intitulés grosse fatigue et épidémie de
flemme quand une partie des Français a
mis les pouces ça peut nous déclencher
un petit sourire mais c'est passionnant
parce que ça pose la question du sens
notamment du travail de la France était
vraiment touchée par la grande flemme
avant d'en débattre je l'attends du
prieze revient sur les enseignements de
cette étude
des Français usés fatigués voire même
touchés par une épidémie de flemme une
récente étude publiée par la Fondation
Jean Jaurès et l'Ifop dresse ce constat
le mode de vie des Français et leur
motivation ont été durement impactés par
la crise sanitaire très clairement on a
pris ce pli en fait de rester chez soi
pour faire toutes sortes de choses et de
moins faire l'effort de ce de se
rencontrer c'est plus la même énergie du
tout
ouais c'est ça complètement changé selon
l'étude 30% des Français se disent moins
motivés dans leur quotidien qu'avant la
période covid le sondage révèle aussi
une démotivation particulièrement élevée
chez les jeunes entre 25 et 34 ans ils
sont 40% à avoué ressentir une baisse de
motivation par rapport à l'avant crise
sanitaire pour Jérémy Peltier directeur
général de la Fondation Jean Jaurès la
société tout entière a comme sombrer
dans une sorte de covidon on a beaucoup
parlé de covidon quand on parlait des
malades et finalement ce qu'on s'est dit
avec James Fourquet c'était que
peut-être la société tout entière était
aussi touché par une forme de covidon
mais finalement une forme de covidon qui
pouvait s'apparenter à une forme de
fatigue un peu généralisée fatigue un
peu de fond qui se traduit notamment par
une baisse de motivation une baisse de
motivation généralisée qui affecte aussi
le monde du travail selon l'étude la
crise sanitaire en bouleversant les
usages professionnels à engendrer son
lot d'angoisse et d'incertitude pour de
nombreux salariés et affecter leur
motivation bon nombre de salariés ont
expérimenté le télétravail chez eux bon
nombre de salariés ont été en chômage
partiel bon nombre de salariés se sont
réinterrogés aussi sur la place du
travail dans leur vie pour toutes ces
raisons là en effet on a constaté qu'à
l'issue de la crise sanitaire il y avait
une réelle baisse de motivation entre 30
à 40% des actifs qui se disent moins
motivés aujourd'hui pour se rendre au
travail autre symptôme de cette grande
flemme un accroissement du temps passé
dans la sphère privée qui s'accompagne
d'un essor d'une économie de la flemme
selon la Fondation Jean Jaurès
plateforme de streaming livraison de
repas à domicile course à la demande
accompagne désormais cette envie de
moins faire les gens sont un peu plus
casanier ont tendance à vouloir rester à
la maison
on peut tout avoir apporté d'un clics et
ben il y a des gens ils préfèrent faire
ça plutôt que de se déplacer pour la
Fondation Jean Jaurès c'est apathie
générale post covid a aussi été nourri
par une accumulation de crise ces
dernières années vagues d'attentat entre
2015 et 2017 mouvement des gilets jaunes
cris social et environnementale ont été
un terrain propice à affecter le moral
des Français
incontestablement un impact
psychologique de toutes ces crises là il
y a pas de distance entre entre les
crises sociales et les crises
individuelles c'est c'est la même chose
qui sont vus sous deux angles différents
alors aujourd'hui évidemment une
réaction qui peut-être un peu salutaire
au contraire c'est de dire je me replie
sur le privé je me replie sur mon
expérience je me replie sur mes amis et
ma famille parce que d'une certaine
manière ça me permet de résister à cette
espèce de de sentiment de délitement qui
nous envahit signe de ces difficultés
rencontrées par les Français la demande
de consultation de psychologue a explosé
depuis la période covid plus 102% en
2021 selon les chiffres du site doctolib
[Musique]
je ne veux pas travailler ce n'est pas
le message que j'envoie au patron Public
Sénat Christopher Baldelli alors qu'on
reprend pour la première fois les
émissions en direct à 18h ce serait
quand même gonflé de ma part non c'est
le refrain du tube de Pink Martini
évidemment est-ce vraiment le nouveau
light motif d'une partie des Français
sommes-nous frappés par une épidémie de
flemme on en débat tout de suite avec
Dominique mesdam bonsoir bienvenue à
vous vous êtes philosophe sociologue
professeur à l'Université Paris Dauphine
pierre cassunoguès bonsoir bon bienvenue
à vous aussi professeur de philosophie à
l'Université Paris 8 Vincennes
Saint-Denis et je cite votre livre la
bienveillance des machines libres
publiées aux éditions du Seuil Richard
berliban soit venu Richard correspondant
en France Europe pour le média suisse
Blick vous avez signé un article sur ce
thème le titre de votre site est la
France paresseuse cette réalité qui
paralyse la République Mathieu
croissanto est toujours évidemment filer
le poste en voilà qui travaille
qui commence à la matinale chez nos amis
de
BFM et qui et qui se retrouve ici en
direct un soir sur deux le constat pour
commencer sur la motivation des des
Français et là on s'appuie vraiment sur
cette étude de la Fondation Jean Jaurès
qui a travaillé avec l'Ifop 30% des
Français en sentiment d'être moins
motivés
qu'avant dans ce qu'ils font au
quotidien depuis la crise sanitaire et
puis sur le le travail 37 % des actifs
on le sentiment d'être moins motivé
qu'avant dans leur travail depuis la
crise sanitaire donc c'est plus
important chez les actifs Dominique
Pédat est-ce que vous appréciez tiens
déjà pour commencer cette expression là
grande flemme ou épidémie de flemme pour
reprendre l'intitulé de l'étude de la
Fondation je la trouve terriblement
dangereuse je pensais à une énorme
confusion entre en effet l'économie de
la flemme c'est à dire le développement
des plateformes de services on appelle
on est dans son canapé et cette idée
qu'il y aurait une épidémie de flemme
alors personnellement ça me semble
complètement faux moi ça fait 20 ou 30
ans que je travaille sur toutes les
enquêtes travail par exemple en 2007
j'avais fait un gros on avait exploité
toutes les enquêtes existantes en Europe
et en France pour comprendre quel était
le rapport des Européens au travail et
ça se dément pas ce qu'on voit c'est des
Français très attachés au travail dont
les attentes à l'égard du travail sont
extrêmement fortes mais qui sont
terriblement déçus par les conditions de
travail et il y a un paradoxe parce que
donc le l'enquête de Jean Jaurès iPhone
nous dit que c'est tout nouveau les il y
aurait plus de centralité du travail
mais moi je peux vous dire que en 1999 à
la fois environ 70% des Français
disaient que le travail était pour eux
très important et en même temps ils
avaient envie que le travail prenne
moins de place en 2003 une autre très
grosse enquête inaid Insee sur qui
s'appelait construit histoire de vie
construction des identités 66% des
Français disaient le travail est moins
important que d'autres choses entre
parenthèses vie sociale vie familiale
vie personnelle donc moi je pense qu'il
y a une accentuation des tendances qui a
une énorme fatigue ça c'est sûr
vraiment fatigue un énorme choc en plus
des crises qui viennent comme ça
alors c'est j'espère
quelque chose vous avez une cause
extérieure qui vient vous frapper la
flemme c'est intérieur gros péché
chiffre le philosophe allemand c'est
vraiment le c'est un trait de caractère
quoi donc c'est radicalement différent
parce que moi je pense qu'il y a une
très grosse fatigue mais qui vient des
conditions de travail alors on y
reviendra évidemment sur les conditions
de travail le sens du travail le rôle
des entreprises pour définir
effectivement leur rôle social même ou
leur rôle politique c'est vraiment une
question que de plus en plus
d'entreprises se pose aujourd'hui mais
déjà sur sur l'étude Jean Jaurès et sur
cette cette idée qu'une partie des
Français deviendrait paresseux qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez vous pire vraiment
une épidémie de pareil je verrai une
bonne nouvelle mais il me semble que
pour moi l'étude de Montreux surtout en
fait une épidémie d'anxiété et et
indépendamment du travail j'ai été
frappé par les pourcentages de français
en particulier jeunes qui disent avoir
la flemme de sortir de chez eux et plus
encore le nombre des sondés qui disent
ne pas se sentir capable de faire face
aux aléas de la vie quotidienne c'est si
on prend les moins de 50 ans c'est près
de 38 %. c'est énorme 38% des gens de
moins de 50 ans qui disent ne pas
pouvoir faire face aux aléas de la vie
et ça ça traduit beaucoup plus de
l'anxiété que de la flemme donc
l'anxiété qui provoque une sorte de
repli sur soi c'est ça on a peur de
sortir de chez nous pour le dire de
façon outrée mais le fait d'être de ne
pas vouloir travailler de ne pas vouloir
sortir de chez soi lorsque c'est lié à
cette à ce sentiment d'une incapacité à
faire face aux aléas de la vie
quotidienne elle traduit beaucoup plus
de l'anxiété que de la queue de la
paresse et justement la paresse comme
vous le disiez très bien l'appareil
c'est quelque chose de volontaire que
d'une certaine façon je choisis je
choisis de ne rien faire à mon avis on
devrait le faire plus souvent mais
l'anxiété c'est je suis pris par une
espèce de peur qui m'empêche de sortir
de faire face à l'extérieur et et c'est
quand même en particulier donc ce
chiffre des sondés qui ont la flemme
entre guillemets mais la flemme c'est
pas le mot qu'utilise les sonder c'est
le mot qui leur est proposé la flemme de
sortir de chez eux c'est difficile pour
moi de ne pas le mettre en relation avec
ces images ce qui passaient au journal
télévisé pendant le confinement de ces
drones nous disons restez chez vous
rentrez chez vous que on a le sentiment
que l'extérieur finalement pour un
certain nombre d'entre nous reste liés à
ce sentiment d'une dangerosité vague
d'une inquiétude effectivement ce
chiffre 45% des Français ont
régulièrement la flemme de sortir de
chez eux on y reviendra sur le les coups
ce qu'on appelle l'économie de de la
flemme la France paresseuse c'était le
titre de votre article Richard Berry
est-ce que vous qui est un observateur
voilà vous avez un œil assez riche sur
la société française depuis plusieurs
années est-ce que finalement vous
reprenez à votre compte une partie des
conclusions de la l'étude de la
Fondation Jean Jaurès est-ce que vous
ressentez quand même
un avant un après covid et dans notre
relation au travail mais pas seulement
au travail à la fête au fait de sortir
de chez soi etc etc et je pense que
quand on regarde la France avec un petit
peu de distance de l'étranger il y a
quand même deux caractéristiques la
première et vous l'avez dit il y a une
anxiété généralisée je m'interroge quand
même est-ce que l'anxiété à un moment
donné ne génère pas de la paresse c'est
qu'est-ce qu'à un moment donné la peur
dominante du travail le stress au
travail ne finit pas par provoquer une
espèce d'épuisement de motivation et ça
je crois que c'est très français quand
même parce que les sondages le montrent
généralement la pétanque pour le travail
et quand même moins forte aujourd'hui en
France qu'elle ne l'était il y a
quelques années et elle est aussi quand
même souvent moins forte en France que
dans d'autres pays voisins et la
deuxième chose moi qui me paraît très
caractéristique c'est que le système
français et là c'est pas qualitatif ce
que je vais dire c'est que le système
français parce que le modèle social est
un modèle quand même à l'aune des pays
européens plus généreux que la moyenne
il peut favoriser à un moment donné ce
type de comportement je vais prendre un
exemple qui est celui de la Suisse qui
est un système beaucoup plus libéral et
encore une fois je ne je n'aimais pas un
avis c'est factuel un système où la
durée d'indemnisation du chômage est
beaucoup plus courte un système où l'âge
de la retraite a déjà été allongé il a
été repoussé et bien le fait est que
vous avez quand même moins l'occasion de
vous poser la question et en plus en
Suisse les rémunérations sont plus
élevées donc le donnant donnant social
et plus en faveur du travail voilà et là
je me demande si ce donnant donnant en
France il est pas devenu aujourd'hui un
peu en défaveur du travail Mathieu tout
dépend à qui on se compare
si vous prenez le Danemark
une démocratie scandinave avec un
système de protection sociale assez
assez ouvert et assez protecteur
là on dit formidable bonheur danois
regardez comme ils sont heureux donc ce
sont pas des gens qui travaillent
tellement plus que nous ils ont un taux
de prélèvement obligatoire extrêmement
élevé mais leur j'allais dire c'est pas
leur paresse parce que je sais pas
comment qualifier ça alors art de vivre
et qualifié de de leçons de bonheur à
travers l'Europe et à travers le monde
nous on a quand même toujours cette
capacité à l'autodénis d'autodénigrement
moi je suis assez frappé par un paradoxe
l'angoisse elle est toujours collective
elle est un peu moins individuelle quand
on interroge les gens est-ce que vous
êtes anxieux pour l'avenir du pays pour
l'avenir de l'économie il y a toujours
des réponses beaucoup plus importantes
que quand on leur demande est-ce que
vous vous êtes anxieux pour votre avenir
personnel pour votre sort pour celui de
vos enfants donc il y a quand même un
paradoxe là dessus et là au moins je je
suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous
c'est que je pense que au-delà
d'engendrer de la paresse le système
engendre du renoncement c'est plutôt que
de la c'est à dire que on est dans une
perte de sens dans une fatigue dans une
ce que vous voulez qui d'une certaine
manière amène les gens à baisser les
bras mais pas forcément à devenir des
personnes il y avait quand même Richard
Berly vous l'avez retenu d'ailleurs le
dans l'image positive des mots quoi et
de certains mots c'est assez frappant ça
c'est quoi c'est le mot si vous me
suivez un canapé
la Fondation Jean Jaurès insiste
beaucoup là-dessus ils ont tout un je
crois qu'ils ont tout un passage aussi
sur le plaid la prolifération des plaids
sur les canapés etc oui c'est à dire
qu'il il y a quand même le sentiment
quand on est en France et encore une
fois quand on la regarde de l'étranger
le sentiment que quelque chose s'est
affaissé autour du travail et cet
affaissement il est générateur alors de
peut-être que le mot qui convient c'est
démobilisation mais mais oui c'est assez
net cela dit j'ai insisté tout à l'heure
le donnant-donnant c'est aussi celui de
la rémunération parce que quand vous
êtes bien payé dans des métiers en plus
difficile naturellement vous plus motivé
alors il y a le mot fatigue on est sur
la sémantique le mot fatigue qui arrive
en tête quand on demande aux Français
comment ils se sentent en ce moment
c'est ce cas rappeler l'un des
co-auteurs de cette étude de la
Fondation Jean Jaurès dans le président
de la forme le directeur général pardon
de la Fondation jeanjass c'est Jérémy
Pelletier on l'écoute il y avait un truc
qui était frappant en fait à l'issue de
la crise sanitaire quand on interrogeait
les Françaises et les françaises sur le
mot qui caractérisait le mieux leur état
d'esprit du moment le terme qui arrivait
en tête à chaque fois dans toutes les
enquêtes dans tous les sondages qu'on
pouvait faire c'était le terme de
fatigue alors que classiquement quand on
demandait aux françaises aux Français
comment vous sentez en ce moment c'est
quoi le premier terme qui vous vient en
tête quand on vous demande de qualifier
votre état d'esprit souvent c'était les
termes de colère de nervosité de
d'inquiétude de lassitude etc etc je
vous propose un zoom sur la motivation
des jeunes Français je vais vous donner
la parole tout de suite Dominique mais
là toujours selon la Fondation Jean
Jaurès 40% des 25 5 34 ans on le
sentiment d'être moins motivé qu'avant
dans ce qu'ils font au quotidien depuis
la création de la crise sanitaire alors
moi ça fait je sais pas j'ai
l'impression que ça fait 40 ans que
j'entends la phrase les jeunes veulent
plus travailler merci donc j'espère ne
jamais devenir plus vue qui la prononce
même si ça m'est peut-être arrivé bref
bon c'est ce que vous ressentez vous
aussi mais bien sûr il y a par exemple
il y a une étude qui a été sortie en 75
je crois par le Centre d'études de
l'emploi ou déjà tout le monde se plaint
du fait que les jeunes ne veulent plus
travailler et quand on regarde bien ce
qu'on avait fait dans le dans l'enquête
dont je vous ai parlé quand on regarde
bien ce que ce que disent les jeunes en
fait ils ont exactement les mêmes
attentes que les autres tranches d'âge
mais en plus intense et en plus leurs
attentes sont plus ils veulent plus
d'autonomie ils veulent plus d'équilibre
vie professionnelle vie personnelle etc
mais je voudrais juste si vous me
permettez à revenir sur cette ce
panorama un peu horrible là que que
qu'on condrait ce collectivement moi je
suis en totale désaccord dire on a on a
un qui n'a jamais été aussi élevé donc
alors ils sont ils sont démotivés où ils
vont bosser depuis 75 le taux d'emploi
n'a jamais été aussi élevé pour toutes
les tranches d'âge et pour les jeunes la
grande démission on a dit ah c'est la
fin du travail pas du tout la grande
démission c'est des gens qui peuvent
enfin lâcher leur boulot insoutenable
pour aller trouver un travail où ils
sont un peu mieux payés ou les
conditions de travail sont un peu
meilleur et les jeunes c'est pareil donc
moi je vois pas du tout de la
démotivation moi je vois vraiment au
centre de tout ça des conditions de
travail vous avez parlé de de
comparaison quand on regarde en
comparaison ce qu'il en est des
conditions de travail en France elles
sont super mauvaises elles sont très
très médiocres on a des organisations
néotéloriennes où les gens n'ont pas
d'autonomie où ils sont pressurés où il
y a peu de syndicats pour défendre les
gens et moi je pense qu'une grande
partie du problème vient de là de
mauvaises conditions de travail font que
les gens ils en ont en effet marre de
leur boulot mais en revanche leurs
attentes elles sont quand même elles
sont quand même énorme plus là dessus la
crise climatique qui est venue en
rajouter une couche je suis tout à fait
d'accord une d'anxiété il y a aussi cet
enchaînement des crises quoi c'est écrit
crise sanitaire et crise climatique et
la crise énergétique
les jeunes en effet d'abord ils s'en
sont pris plein la figure pendant la
crise et puis les je ne faut pas oublier
parce que quand même la les gens qui
sont sur leur canapé là c'est quand même
pas tous les gens c'est pas tous les
jeunes non mais dans son canapé et les
travailleurs essentiels 4 millions
600000 personnes sont pas du tout ils
étaient pas du tout dans leur canapé
mais à côté de ça il y a aussi tant
d'entreprises alors ça rejoint la
question du sens du travail qui arrive
pas à embaucher oui mais ils arrivent
pas à embaucher sur des postes enfin
dont on sait ce qui sont peu attractifs
comme on est c'est vraiment un
euphémisme peu attractif c'est-à-dire
son mal payés avec des conditions de
travail très dures
très difficile de concilier des horaires
imprévisibles on sait bien et donc ils
ont beau essayer de de d'améliorer tout
ça bah ça marche pas mais bon voilà ne
disons pas que c'est de la démotivation
et moi c'est ce qui me fait peur dans
tout ça c'est que on finisse par se dire
ce que ce que la grande tendance en
France ah bah c'est chômeurs qui les
chômeurs et les allocataires du RSA en
fait ils veulent pas bosser ils sont
paresseux simplement c'est la proue de
la France et les plus paresseux des
paresseux non attention non c'est trop
dangereux si on reste sur la question de
la de la jeunesse pierre cassuno et
finalement c'est c'est quoi c'est une
sorte de déprime de dépression à
laquelle on assiste on essaie de mettre
des mots sur le phénomène là depuis tout
à l'heure si on dit c'est pas de la
flemme c'est de l'anxiété vous m'avez
dit est-ce que vous iriez jusqu'à
employer des termes qui sont plus de
l'ordre de la psychologie ou de la
psychiatrie
de dépression oui peut-être oui je
tiendrai sur le terme de donc d'anxiété
mais moi le d'une certaine façon dans
cette idée de de travailler moins c'est
quelque chose que je voudrais défendre
c'est-à-dire l'idée qui aurait
effectivement une France paresseuse me
semblerait une excellente nouvelle et
que
cette idéologie du travail le cette idée
que ne rien faire c'est c'est mal c'est
une idée donc dont on peut par exemple
avec Max Weber faire remonter l'origine
au XVIIe siècle que Max Weber voit au
fondement du capitalisme et qu'il faut
voir maintenant au fondement du
réchauffement climatique c'est à dire
s'il y a un réchauffement climatique
c'est parce que nous nous voulons
travailler toujours plus produire
toujours plus consommer toujours plus
mais d'une façon ou d'une autre à moins
d'imaginer une sorte de miracle
technologique qui nous permettra de
brûler de l'énergie sans polluer pour le
dire très vite il va falloir travailler
moins et consommer moins et que le fait
de travailler de ne rien faire de ne pas
travailler c'est culpabilisant on se
sent mal à ne pas travailler et le mot
il y a très peu de mots en fait qui
désignent cette inaction et qui sont
positifs la flemme c'est négatif
d'ailleurs même dans le dans le dans le
dans l'étude la flemme reste négative le
seul point d'espoir pour moi c'est que
les 18 25 ans sont ceux qui donnent le
plus de positivité à la flemme mais
traîner c'est négatif et et je pense
vraiment qu'à leur à la fois de
l'automatisation et du réchauffement
climatique il faut apprendre à ne pas
travailler et que c'est difficile en
fait est-ce que c'est est-ce que dans un
contexte de concurrence internationale
Richard Werly on peut on peut porter ce
discours là ces valeurs là comme
finalement peut-être même un projet de
réforme que que qu'une force politique
pourrait
essayer de mener au pouvoir et on va
parler de la réaction des politiques
français dans un instant ce qui est sûr
c'est que le type d'argument que vous
venez de développer que j'entends tout à
fait le tenir par exemple devant un
public suisse ça serait quand même
beaucoup plus compliqué parce que là on
est dans un pays de culture protestante
les types du capitalisme etc donc on est
encore dans un pays extrêmement rivé sur
le travail mais après tout ces
différences culturel pour moi elles sont
pas un problème elles existent chaque
pays a son propre en quelque sorte
baromètre par rapport au travail par
rapport à l'appareil ou au moment de
liberté non moi ce que je crois c'est
que il y a une manière quand même de
positiver vous en avez parlé à propos de
la jeunesse positiver la flemme et il
faut savoir ce que les gens mettent
derrière par exemple que les jeunes et
moins d'appétence pour un certain type
de travail franchement il y a pas qu'en
France que c'est vrai c'est vrai partout
c'est une tendance généralisée de la
Genèse d'aujourd'hui d'être beaucoup
plus regardante sur un certain nombre de
critères alors c'est facile de dire ils
sont regardants parce qu'ils veulent pas
bosser non ils sont en gardant parce que
il y a des critères qui sont peut-être
pas ceux de nos générations et qu'on a
de la peine et qu'on a de la difficulté
à comprendre c'est une façon de mettre
aussi la pression sur certaines
entreprises pour qu'elle fasse évaluer
leur modèle etc et puis l'autre élément
je suis très sensible à ce que ce que
vous disiez à l'instant c'est-à-dire
c'est l'organisation du travail je crois
qu'il y a des organisations du travail
qui génèrent je sais pas si on peut
appeler ça du bonheur mais en tout cas
du bien-être au travail des
organisations où les gens se sentent
responsabilité c'est responsaillé moins
pressurisée il y a des organisations qui
génèrent le contraire or la France
effectivement c'est quand même l'anxiété
synonyme de travail et je dirais même
elle est un peu surexploitée c'est à
dire en gros un employé qui n'est pas
anxieux un employé qui n'est pas sous
tension le patron est pas très content
je pardon d'être un peu dans la
caricature mais c'est l'impression que
j'ai c'est pas du tout vrai dans un pays
comme l'Allemagne c'est pas du tout vrai
dans un pays comme la Suisse ou le
patron qui c'est vrai peut s'appuyer sur
des lois très libérales il faut le dire
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile pour lui
par exemple de licencié un employé mais
il va plutôt chercher à avoir des
employés heureux alors Mathieu on va
parler de voir comment le leader
politique se sont appropriés cette cette
thématique et on remonte à l'automne
dernier oui c'était la rentrée dernière
à l'occasion d'un débat qui a divisé
quoi la gauche sur la valeur travail et
la paresse alors le débat il a été lancé
par l'enfant terrible de la nupesse le
communisme Fabien Roussel à la fête de
l'humain qui avait acc vous inviter en
déclarant que la gauche doit défendre le
travail et ne pas être la gauche des
allocations et des Mines sociaux alors
le patron du PCF a été repris en plein
vol par la plupart de ses alliés qu'il
accusait de faire le jeu de la droite
parce que c'est plutôt d'habitude la
valeur travail une thématique selon eux
de droite et l'écologie Sandrine
Rousseau avec elle décidait de prendre
le contre-pied de Fabien Roussel en
défendant pour sa part un droit à la
paresse dont on a parlé il y a quelques
minutes on a droit à la paresse on a un
droit à la transition des métiers on a
le droit aussi de faire des pauses dans
sa vie et surtout il nous faut retrouver
du temps le sens du partage et la
semaine de quatre jours avait déclaré la
députée écologiste de Paris et ce n'est
pas un débat tout à fait nouveau à
gauche
près de 140 ans le droit apparaît ça
aurait fait le titre de d'un livre
publié en 1880 par Paul Lafargue Paul
Lafargue c'était le gendre de Karl Marx
alors c'est un porche c'est un pamphlet
à la base qui est devenu un classique à
gauche pour démythifier la valeur
travail et donc c'est un débat je vais
dire vieux comme la gauche pour essayer
de de clarifier en car des gens un peu
mais pour que le téléspectateur
comprenne pour la Fargue et ses
héritiers le travail qui vient du latin
tripalium on le rappelle qui est un
instrument de torture c'est une
aliénation qui nourrit à la fois par le
système capitaliste aussi par la
culpabilisation géocrétienne et qui fait
souffrir les classes laborieuses comme
on disait à l'époque parce que les
classes à glorieuses ont à offrir que
leur bras c'est la définition du sens de
prolétaire et leur Brel l'offre à un
système qu'il exploite et qui fait que
les exploitent et qui leur demande
toujours plus ça je caricature un peu
mais c'est la vision que développe la
Fargue dans le droit d'apparie à
l'inverse toujours à gauche chez les
marxistes il y a des défenseurs de la
valeur travail qui disent que le
problème c'est pas tant le travail en
lui-même au contraire Marx considère
d'ailleurs que le travail permet à
l'homme de se transformer de s'émanciper
ce qui pose problème à leurs yeux c'est
l'organisation du travail les conditions
de travail et la répartition des fruits
de ce travail et pourquoi ce débat il
raisonne particulièrement aujourd'hui
parce qu'il oppose à mes yeux deux
visions qui s'éloignent irrémédiablement
ou de vision j'allais dire
irrégonciliables pour paraphraser un
grand penseur de la gauche aujourd'hui
disparaît du monde politique
la première c'est celle du droit
d'apparaît c'est un peu celle que vous
avez développé c'est celle qui considère
que la priorité c'est de sortir du
toujours plus c'est la gauche on peut
reconnaître dans la décroissance qui
veut ralentir la marge du monde parce
que elle estime que la marche du monde
est devenue folle et elles veulent la
remplacer par un toujours moins ou
plutôt moins de travail moins de
consommation moins de croissance moins
de vitesse et puis l'autre gauche c'est
une gauche plus classique qui continue
de croire au progrès technique aux
technologiques et qui considère que la
redistribution des richesses le tient
que si on produit les richesses et que
l'objectif n'est pas moins produire mais
de mieux répartir c'est à dire de
redistribuer avec plus de justice je le
disais tout à l'heure les fruits de la
croissance dans la société politiquement
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est la
première qu'elle va en poupe on est plus
chez les insoumis chez les écolos j'ai
une partie des socialistes sur cette
réflexion autour de la décroissance pour
simplifier mais voilà sur comment
consommer moins ou mieux reste une
question à mes yeux pour la gauche y
a-t-il un avenir après la sieste
attention
qui se remette à travailler c'est ça
pour certains d'entre c'est ce que vous
sous-entendez avec avec cette petite
pique de Dominique MEDA c'est vrai qu'on
peut est-ce que d'une certaine façon la
gauche qu'on appelait la gauche de
gouvernement a pas louper le coche sur
cette question là de de la valeur de du
sens du travail il y aurait tellement de
choses à raconter moi j'ai écrit en 1995
un livre qui s'appelait le travail une
valeur en voie de disparition c'était
j'étais encore plutôt dans la philo à
l'époque et donc c'était une un peu
comme ce que vous avez dit
l'idée que je développais c'était que ça
serait intéressant de réduire
collectivement la place que le travail
occupé dans nos vies pour développer des
activités politiques citoyennes mais
aussi familiales pour mieux répartir le
travail entre les hommes et les femmes
et donc mon idée c'était que les hommes
lâchent un peu le travail pour que les
femmes puissent s'impliquer pleinement
dans dans l'emploi bon à l'époque ça a
fait un gros débat notamment parce qu'on
a pris mon livre comme un diagnostic et
donc les les sociologues répondaient
mais c'est pas vrai que la valeur
travail a disparu la valeur travail est
là les gens sont très attachés au
travail ce qui donné envie après d'aller
faire des enquêtes sur ces sur ces
questions là donc et j'aimerais en fait
rajouter quelque chose sur alors on a eu
un gros débat sur est-ce qu'il faut se
libérer du travail ou libérer le travail
c'est-à-dire l'idée c'était est-ce que
le travail est complètement contaminé
par les logiques économiques et le
capitalisme donc alors à ce moment-là
faut réduire sa place puis s'en
débarrasser et développer des espaces
plus intéressants à côté ou bien est-ce
qu'on va pouvoir libérer le travail
faire des choses intéressantes au sein
du travail et c'est là que reviennent
toutes les questions de d'organisation
du travail par exemple
considérer que certaines machines
peuvent faire un autre place les
tâches les moins intéressantes et je
trouve que là où le ou la chose se
complique c'est que certes
l'automatisation elle pourrait réduire
le temps de travail mais moi il me
semble que si on veut s'occuper vraiment
de la crise climatique et la prendre au
sérieux on va avoir besoin de plus de
travail plus de travail humain moins de
travail machinique ce que ça consomme de
l'énergie plus de travail humain et donc
ça voilà c'est un petit une petite chose
complexe en plus pire question c'est
politiquement parce que vous l'avez au
cutter mais c'est difficile de défendre
la paresse
oui ou encore une fois parce qu'on a
cité mais il y a pas beaucoup de voix
qui qui a très peu il y a très peu de
voix parce qu'on a cette espèce de
culpabilité à ne pas travailler et vous
avez tout à fait raison que le travail
n'est pas seulement une valeur de droite
il y a un roman extraordinaire de de
l'écrivain russe plateau neuf qui se
passe dans la Russie dans l'URSS des
années 20 et les les personnages
creusent un trou pour rien en fait sont
les fondations de l'humanité du progrès
de l'humanité il creuse un trou qui ne
sert à rien pour travailler et toutes
les maximes de l'URSS donc pour le
travail pour la productivité sont
illustrées à partir de ce trou qui ne va
servir à rien qui ne fait que faire du
travail
donc effectivement il y a une un
particulier dans le marxisme il y a une
une
[Musique]
apologie disons de de la valeur travail
ou cette étude de la Fondation Jean
Jaurès sort la grande flemme comme la
France perd le goût de l'effort
aujourd'hui quand même Richard Werly
c'est une valeur reprise par la droite
en France et pas seulement en France
cette valeur travail c'est surtout une
valeur je sais pas si c'est une valeur
mais c'est surtout un constat qui
convient à la droite ce qui est
d'ailleurs ironique c'est que le Figaro
Magazine faisait sa couverture sur une
étude de la Fondation Jean Jaurès le
cercle de réflexion le plus le plus à
droite ils le font c'est parce que ça
alimente un certain nombre de tests de
droite mais je crois que les médias les
médias et au-delà disons l'univers du
divertissement a aussi une
responsabilité c'est-à-dire que là ce
qu'on appelait la paresse la
démobilisation je sais pas quel thème on
peut employer mais la réticence à
travailler la manière dont vous
l'illustrez peut conduire à des
comportements très différents si vous
illustrez ça par le sofa le canapé être
stoïque devant son écran et attendre
qu'on vous serve tout effectivement
c'est vraiment je dirais la pire flemme
en quelque sorte parce qu'en plus c'est
victime de l'énergie celle-là et puis si
vous êtes chez vous et que vous faites
autre chose si vous avez une autre
activité je sais pas que vous passez
plus de temps et que vos enfants que
vous contribuez à l'éducation dans un
quartier on peut même dire que Laurent
on peut même dire que l'ennui est
créatif voilà le moment où des enfants
s'ennuient c'est peut-être le moment où
ils viennent ils inventent des solutions
les médias ont quand même une tendance
radicale a toujours illustrer par
exemple ce cette ce peu d'envie de
travail ou ce manque d'envie de travail
par des clichés qui sont vraiment des
clichés paresseux et là il faudrait
peut-être faire attention si dans les
représentations qu'on donne parce que
c'est elle qui à mon avis engendre les
réponses au sondage vous la donne mais
on parle de l'économie de la flemme
juste après absolument alors pour moi ne
rien faire ça n'est pas regarder son
écran que justement les nouvelles
technologies rendent encore plus
difficile de ne rien faire parce que
quand on regarde son écran sa plateforme
on est dans un rapport de travail et de
consommation on brûle de l'énergie le
plus souvent on travaille on travaille
en laissant vous donner on travaille en
regardant de la publicité on contribue à
produire des choses qui ont de la valeur
donc on travaille même si les fort n'est
pas le même que on travaille
non non on travaille avec un effort
différent de celui d'un maçon mais on
produit on produit quelque chose qui a
des valeurs par exemple on produit de la
valeur notamment avec toutes ces données
que les gens sauf que c'est elle
exactement
on travaille en produisant des données
mais on travaille aussi en produisant du
contenu quand je fais une vidéo je la
mets sur Youtube ou une autre plateforme
je produis un contenu qui ne
m'appartient plus donc on travaille pour
moi la vraie paresse elle est justement
d'éteindre son écran et elle est
d'autant plus difficile que nous avons
dans nos poches ces machines qui sont
destinées à nous captiver alors vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure l'économie
de la flemme je rappelle un des éléments
issus de cette étude de la Fondation on
a déjà vu ce chiffre mais je vous le
redonne 45% des Français ça va au-delà
du travail c'est pour ça que je re-
propose ce chiffre on régulièrement la
flemme de sortir de chez eux je propose
à Steve journal de nous rejoindre de
nouveaux sur ce plateau Steve en faisant
attention de ne pas trébucher comme tout
à l'heure il faut sortir vous connaissez
mieux les lieux que moi on va parler du
secteur du transport des des voyageurs à
la demande évidemment qui qui surf lui
aussi sur voilà sur cette paresse cette
flemme je ne sais pas quel terme
employer à l'issue de ce débat secteur
en tout cas qui a explosé ces dernières
années vous avez la flemme on a le VTC
c'est un slogan utilisé par une célèbre
plateforme de véhicules avec chauffeur
et effectivement ce type de plateforme a
aujourd'hui plus de 10 ans Hubert est
arrivé presque incognito on s'en
rappelle en France en décembre 2011
aujourd'hui c'est géant économique on va
voir quelques chiffres Thomas 5 millions
d'utilisateurs ont réalisé au moins une
course en 2021 ils étaient 3 millions il
est encore quelques années le chiffre
d'affaires d'Hubert en 2020 c'est 76,5
millions d'euros en France on compte
aujourd'hui 30 000 chauffeurs en
activité dans l'Hexagone et des
chauffeurs qui nous livrent aussi des
repas parce qu'on a souvent la flemme de
faire la cuisine oui vous faites
peut-être partie de ces Français Thomas
qui se font livrer au moins un repas à
domicile par mois c'est en tout cas ce
qui ressort d'une enquête Ifop réalisée
en 2021 52% des Français ont recours au
moins une fois par an à ces livraisons à
la maison pour 23% des Français c'est
même au moins une fois par mois alors
faut-il y voir un aspect générationnel
en tout cas si seulement 25% des 65 ans
et plus se font livrer au moins une fois
par an un repas à domicile cette
proportion est un 60% chez les 35-49 ans
et même 78% chez les moins de 35 ans
évidemment ces nouvelles habitudes de
consommation se lisent dans les chiffres
d'affaires des plateformes uber ou
encore deliveroo sont en pleine
expansion et face à l'expansion de ces
plateformes les pouvoirs publics tentent
d'encadrer ces nouvelles pratiques et
c'est lancé très lent à se mettre en
place c'est pas une question flamme mais
plutôt de rapport de force il faut
savoir que les plateformes considèrent
les livreurs comme des travailleurs
indépendants ce qui veut dire qu'ils
n'ont ni salaire minimum ni congés payés
ni couverture sociale alors depuis
plusieurs années beaucoup de politiques
demandent à ce que ces travailleurs
indépendants bénéficient du statut de
salarié c'est une demande aussi des
syndicats et qui revient régulièrement
devant les tribunaux sur un terrain plus
politique la Commission européenne vient
d'adopter des règles concernant les
conventions collectives les travailleurs
pourront désormais se regrouper pour
négocier collectivement de meilleures
conditions de travail à cela le Sénat
dit un grand oui puisque dans la foulée
une résolution a été adoptée mi-novembre
par la Chambre haute elle appelle à
fixer un cadre juridique plus clair pour
ceux qui travaillent dans cette nouvelle
économie merci beaucoup Steve Jourdain
pour pouvoir
flemmarder ou rester tranquillement chez
soi on fait travailler les autres et pas
forcément dans de bonnes conditions
c'est ça la leçon qu'il faut absolument
qu'il faut et donc avec mes collègues
vous savez plusieurs années qu'on
regarde ce secteur et on travaille
notamment avec les inspecteurs de la
sécurité sociale qui cherchent à
récupérer les cotisations parce que ce
qu'il faut quand même dire c'est que en
effet ces plateformes en profitent pour
exploiter la main d'oeuvre qui travaille
puisque donc on oblige les travailleurs
à prendre le statut de
d'auto-entrepreneur et donc ça veut dire
que ça leur permet d'échapper ces
grandes entreprises aux droits du
travail puisqu'il y a pas de congés et
pas d'indynamisation chômage
c'est-à-dire que quand vous déconnectez
un chauffeur il se passe rien pour lui
enfin il a perdu son son
ce qui lui permet de vivre mais il y a
aucune indemnité chômage et puis ces
grandes entreprises elles ne payent pas
non plus de cotisation sociale donc
c'est c'est vraiment ça va pas du tout
quoi c'est un détricotage là que du
salariat qui qui s'opère et donc vous
avez des pas mal de d'organismes qui
tentent de récupérer les cotisations et
ce qui est très intéressant c'est qu'il
y a des contentieux depuis des années
parce que très souvent les chauffeurs
ils finissent par se plaindre justement
d'être déconnecté n'importe comment ou
d'être maltraités et tous les procès qui
a eu jusqu'à maintenant on montrait que
c'était bien des salariés parce que
c'est pas l'entreprise qui décide du
site une salarié c'est le juge et le
juge jusque là a toujours dit chez
desdiverous chez Hubert et partout que
ce sont bien des salariés et donc il
faudrait absolument en effet salarié ces
personnes alors pour l'instant les
entreprises résistent parce
qu'évidemment ça leur coûterait plus
cher elle sera obligée de payer des
cotisations sociales et de respecter le
droit du travail mais donc ce sont des
comportements qui ne sont pas bons pour
pour les pour les travailleurs ce qui
est très intéressant on pense que c'est
dans nos pays occidentaux dans nos
démocraties que le droit du travail est
le plus avancé ce qu'il a plupart du
temps et le cas mais dans ces
professions de livreur et autres c'est
souvent dans les pays du Sud que la
mobilisation est la plus forte par
exemple en Inde il y a des syndicats
très très forts qui sont implantés parmi
les livreurs pour défendre leurs droits
sociaux bon bien évidemment dans le
système indien en Indonésie également
donc parce que là il y a une
prolifération énorme de ces types
d'emplois et finalement ils ont plus de
leviers sur le système que peut-être ces
chauffeurs en France je voudrais qu'on
termine il nous reste quelques minutes
sur le l'équilibre entre travail et vie
personnelle et on va écouter une
consultante RH qui alors c'est
intéressant parce qu'elle donne des
conseils sur les réseaux sociaux et
elvisky les plus jeunes puisqu'elle est
sur TikTok on l'écoute bien surtout un
nouveau mouvement qui s'appelle The
croyauting ou silent cuisination ou
silent Rinder on s'en fout ça veut dire
la démission silencieuse et ça consiste
en quoi et bah tu restes en poste tu
fais ton travail professionnel mais tu
refuses les heures supplémentaires tu
refuses de répondre aux emails ou au
téléphone en dehors des horaires de
travail et tu refuses d'assumer des
responsabilités qui ne font pas partie
de la description de le poste tout de
l'ambition de ce mouvement c'est de dire
non au stress et oui à la santé mentale
au travail pour bien distinguer vie
perso et vie professionnelle pierre
cassuno est-ce qu'il y a une un décalage
générationnel je vais peut-être être
volontairement caricatural entre des
patrons ou des cadres dirigeants qui
forcément bon voilà on sont un peu plus
avancés en âge et une nouvelle
génération qui arrive sur le marché du
travail en posant comme première
question un entretien d'embauche combien
de jours de télétravail c'est comment le
comment le le cadre de travail est
organisé
quels seront mes rapports avec ma
hiérarchie est-ce que vous voyez un
voilà une cassure générationnelle ou pas
alors je ne suis pas sociologue
d'avoir un avis comme ça mais mais en
tout cas en tant que philosophe je
défendrai effectivement l'idée de ne pas
répondre aux emails en dehors des heures
de travail et ce que je trouve frappant
c'est que justement elle
l'intervenante face cette ces remarques
sur une vidéo TikTok c'est à dire sur en
même temps un média qui est extrêmement
aliénant et captivant qui est
le paradisme du travail gratuit ou elle
est en train de faire un travail gratuit
c'est à dire elle fait une vidéo pour
laquelle elle n'est pas payée et à
partir de laquelle Tik Tok gagne de
l'argent vie donc elle est en train de
faire le contraire de ce qu'elle ce
qu'elle
dit elle-même
et en
captivant l'attention des internautes
qui eux-mêmes de cette façon travaille
donc d'une certaine façon
voilà je pense que en particulier chez
les gens jeunes qui utilisent plus ces
plateformes des plateformes comme Tik
Tok induisent un déplacement du travail
et peut-être une réduction disons ou une
réticence vis-à-vis du travail officiel
en quelque sorte au profit de ce travail
invisible non rémunéré qui a lieu sur
TIC donc ça c'est la réponse du
philosophe et la réponse de la
sociologue et philosophe à cette
question du GAP générationnel oui il
faut voir que les nouvelles générations
qui arrivent elles sont toujours plus
éduquées donc elles arrivent avec des
attentes qui sont toujours plus
différences de plus d'autonomie plus de
conciliation faut pas oublier que plus
on avance dans le temps plus les femmes
travaillent et donc il faut bien
quelqu'un que les hommes aident à un peu
à prendre en charge les activités
domestiques et familiales donc de fait
on a besoin de plus de temps mais je
voulais réagir aussi sur la grande
nouveauté de ça ça s'appelle le
ça s'appelait le freinage c'est à dire
on en fait on essaye de surtout ralentir
la cadence pour pas que derrière ils
augmentent encore les les
objectifs à tenir donc est-ce qu'il y a
un vrai faux c'est générationnel je
pense c'est ce que montre un peu les
enquêtes dont on dispose aujourd'hui
d'une part des jeunes qui ont à peu près
les mêmes attentes que les autres mais
beaucoup plus intense donc je vais à la
fois bien gagner ma vie avoir un travail
intéressant un travail qui dégrade pas
un travail utile etc et dans une
entreprise qui a intégré ces notions là
absolument et en même temps il y a pas
une catégorie Jeune homogène il y a des
jeunes très qualifiés qui ont le choix
qui vont pouvoir justement mettre les
entreprises en compétition puis à ceux
qui sont moins qualifiés qu'ont pas
beaucoup de choix merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce à ce débat
pire questionneuse je vais rappeler le
titre de votre livre publié aux éditions
du Seuil la bienveillance des machines
voilà je vous donne rendez-vous demain
pour un nouveau numéro de sens public
depuis votre prochain rendez-vous
politique à l'islevard l'ancienne
présente par intérim du parti LR les
républicains des petits du 12 à l'invité
Dorian Mancini dans la matinale de
Public Sénat ce sera à 8h du matin belle
soirée à toutes et à tous